[Music]
hello hi how's life how is life can I
ask you a
followup what is
life life is an incurable sexually
transmitted
condition no
cure I didn't say disease I said
condition condition herpes is a disease
you are a doctor is a condition I
understand I feel like we were talking
about this a little bit during the break
there's some people myself included I
just can't accept this that's my big
question is is what is this what what is
happening I'm looking at you I'm sitting
here we're filming it what is this all
about well according to Sir Arthur
Edington one of the greatest scientists
in the world something unknown is doing
we don't know what
hey
deac
a that's why they called me deep
Puck deep Puck deep deep
a that's kind of the sound Bill the cat
from Bloom County made no it's a is
infinity and C is the point I think we
all knew that c was the
man you get it yes I I'm I I'm Legit a
big big fan are you aware that you're in
a Kanye West song I was just listening
to it who is
he is
that is that the ultimate expression of
transcendence when you don't even know
who Kanye West
is is he a priest
sort
of he he's a minister of Beats and
Rhymes he's a he's a rap he's a rap
man Kanye said
had
had me floating feel like Deepak
Chopra I think he's referring to
schinger cat you know about that right
what is it Scat shing's Cat shorty does
scat shinger he was a Quantum physicist
shinga oh shinga you know and he spoke
about the cat being dead and alive so
that's his
so Kanye if you're watching that's your
dead and alive both and Alive yeah
it's also called
complimentarity I think I understand
good a wave and a
particle sacred and profane there we go
up and down yeah yeah yeah hot and cold
right sure I love that you're really
dumbing this down for me ice cream and I
dropped my ice cream sure
I think I
[Music]
understand